je pense pas que y'a vraiment des trucs
l'asie finalement il faut se laisser
vivre s'est laissé porter par les décors
par les figurants par les gens qui vous
entourent aussi parfois et c'est ça qui
nous inspire un jeu blanc différence un
personnage
le pitch du film c'est en un mot c'est
un vulgaire voleur du nom d'ali baba
c'est un film familial c'est l'histoire
banale bien c'est qu'elle fut très fier
de vous annoncer que ses propres
cascades sur ce film et c'est très
important pour moi de le faire
dis moi que le solo de la houle ouais tu
as quand même monsieur par contre tu
dégages rien mais c'est pour savoir
c'est un rêve de gosse quoi je pense que
l'enfant que j'étais aurait adoré me
voir là vient de loin ne cherchez pas
son coeur est libre et le chalet à la
douce il est riche
jean pas impossible de faire sans vendre
par colas les chances bad et du da hien
s'apprête le génie du lieu unique de 35
40 points comptant le tout ce qui est ce
m je suis amoureux de mes comédiens
quand je suis derrière un combo il
suffit qu'on livre la moindre petite
émotion elle me fait en effet le plus
sympa dans l'ensemble c'est là c'est la
complicité avec mes partenaires
c'était un film pour adultes qui plaira
aux enfants
là
et tout le monde fait